if you're looking for a job in new york
starting may 15th you'll be able to see
what positions will pay on a whole lot
more job postings this is thanks to a
new law that passed in january requiring
nearly all new york city companies to
disclose expected salary ranges for all
open positions this is a big deal
because of the size of new york city's
economy many of the biggest companies
have operations in new york pay
transparency exists to some degree in
several places in the u.s but new york
city would join only colorado in
requiring this information be included
in job postings i think it'll make a
difference in a really positive way for
job seekers especially women and
black people and people of color but
some businesses have voiced concern that
it will cause more harm than good so
what does this new law mean for job
seekers employees and companies how will
it impact the city's labor market and
will it be an effective way to fight pay
inequities
new york city's pay transparency law was
introduced in 2018 but no action was
taken until last december it comes at a
time
when the labor market is really tight
and when the power dynamics have already
sort of shifted to employees the law
covers nearly every employer hiring in
the city except those with fewer than
four employees and if companies don't
comply they could be fined up to 250 000
or face other civil penalties new york
city officials have told me that
basically at first they plan to not
focus as much on fines but i'm just
making sure that people comply and
understand this rule while the
commission on human rights will do some
investigating on its own most of the
time it will act following a complaint
this mandate joins another law in new
york that passed in 2017 which banned
private employers from pressing job
seekers to disclose their salary history
the first group that will benefit from
this new law
job seekers by seeing pay ranges they
can be more prepared going into salary
negotiations and only apply for jobs
that pay their desired salary this rule
will also enable existing employees to
compare their pay with those stated in
open roles many employment lawyers and
others expect existing employees to go
to their bosses and say hey i see the
salary ranges posted why am i not at the
high end of that range but this law
could be particularly significant for
women and people of color two groups who
have been historically underpaid
according to the u.s census bureau's
most recent national data women in the
u.s make 30 percent less than men and
that gap is wider for most women of
color
paris chandler is the founder and ceo of
black tech pipeline an organization that
helps black technologists get jobs at
companies across the us she says pay
transparency will help prevent
candidates from underselling themselves
in the interview process when you don't
know what to ask for it it brings on a
lot a lot of stress anxiety and imposter
syndrome because you don't know what to
value yourself at especially as someone
who's used to being underserved one
group that's pushing back against this
law is the partnership for new york city
a prominent business group that
represents over 300 major companies in
new york city it intends to push for the
city to delay implementation of the law
to the end of the year
catherine wilde the group's president
and ceo says the law would be difficult
to implement especially with so many
remote jobs and that in some industries
salary is only one component of an
employee's total compensation often like
in the financial services industry it's
a small component of total compensation
but you don't really know what the
compensation is going to be like for
performance bonuses or in the case of
the tech startup sector the equity
opportunities and in a competitive labor
market like new york city she says this
could put employers at a disadvantage
the idea that somehow you're putting out
there the maximum you will pay cuts you
off from talent and gives your
competitors an opportunity to outbid you
she added that the law would negatively
impact hospitals and small businesses
which are both experiencing staffing
shortages
new york city's mandate comes about a
year after colorado's pay transparency
law went into effect and there companies
have handled the law in different ways
some got around the disclosure
requirements by specifying in their
listings that the work can't be done in
the state others posted salaries with
ranges of one hundred thousand dollars
or more but overall the results from
colorado have been pretty positive
according to job seekers and others most
jobs now include salary information on
them the state has done a lot to sort of
educate companies on how to comply with
this
and as a result you can then look at
postings from big companies like amazon
and others
and see what a software engineering role
in in colorado might pay for example or
what a pharmacist at walmart might pay
in colorado it gives people a sense for
sort of what the jobs pay there even if
the pay might be different in someone
else's region a colorado trade group
sought an injunction against the rule in
2021 though a federal judge denied that
request employment lawyers say they
expect similar lawsuits against new
york's measure before it goes into
effect in may
over the next few months experts say
more details about the law are expected
to come out like how companies will be
expected to comply and what the
enforcement mechanism might look like i
think many people are watching new york
city's law just because it could have
ripple effects for other economies
around the country other cities and
states may follow new york city here and
put in place similar legislation